you make me laugh a lot
there's a ton of hurry up and wait on
set which means downtime for the actors
a new best friend is just the thing to
pass the time three two one million
let's check out who met their BFFs while
shooting
me yes
number one the real life relationship
between Iman and Yasmine is comparable
to miss Marvel's Kamala and nakias at
least so says Yasmine God I love that
girl it's just heartwarming the way they
poke at each other but are there for
each other no matter when they need it
or what they need to talk about it's
just a true authentic female teenage
friendship Yasmine also loves that their
friendship in the show isn't over
dramaticized or catty either I couldn't
imagine being the Nokia to anyone else's
Kamala number two from random dance
parties to balloon War pranks Noah
schnapp and Millie Bobby Brown are the
best of friends so good of friends
they've even made a marriage pact we
said if we're not married by 40 we will
get married together because we'd be
good roommates yeah just roomies and
separate bedrooms for sure oh my God
you're so messy despite not actually
having a lot of on-screen time together
on stranger things until season four the
pair bonded very early into filming and
have grown up together number three
don't ghost the Bros I really do
genuinely love working with Anthony I
mean like his presence you know
Sebastian Stan and Anthony Mackey first
became friends on the set of Captain
America the Winter Soldier but they
really solidified that friendship on the
Press tour there was a fake few to
Brewing thanks to Mackie not responding
to a text about Stan's Christmas tree
we're taking a break Stan clarified
though saying you have to understand I
love him that's that's the real problem
like like I I love him like I actually
miss him ugh heartbreaking number four
Zendaya makes friends wherever she goes
it's no wonder she's the kind of person
we all dream of being talented funny
smart ambitious kind fashionable we
could go on so she's going to come up a
couple of times today but first we're
focusing on Euphoria it's okay to have a
few BFFs when you're traveling all over
to work you need it to keep you sane
Zendaya and Hunter Schaefer have been
seen out in public at award shows no
surprise there but also hockey games
they have a ridiculous nickname for each
other boob we can't say we know the
reason behind the nickname but it's um
Charming in the first season Hunter
endearingly said Z was my main scene
partner for most of this season and I
just feel so lucky to come out of this
experience with a new best friend number
5. The Rock and the Heart met on the set
of Central Intelligence and have the
best romance you know how sometimes when
people get under your skin and you just
hate them sometimes friendships look a
lot like feuding so is the case with
Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart who have
done at least half a dozen big
blockbuster movies together you think
everyone's like hey there's Kevin great
but you know number six Shailene Woodley
and Miles Teller have been friends ever
since they starred in The Spectacular
Now carrying that friendship onto
Divergent and Beyond they even went on
vacation together in Hawaii with their
significant others of the time back in
2021. Woodley was overly gushy with
teller on Instagram over top gun
Maverick saying proud sister moment
happening over here Bravo number seven
before there was Euphoria there was
Spider-Man Tom Holland Zendaya and Jacob
adelon became an Inseparable Trio we're
just best friends we really are best
friends when you spend so much time
together on set and then more time
together while you're promoting the
movie you get a chance to really know
each other from the moment we met each
other we all really hit it off I
remember on Spider-Man 1 just becoming
like the best of friends here's hoping
Jacob never felt like a third wheel
around Tom and Zendaya number eight
Scarlett Johansson and Chris Evans have
done a lot together when you invest so
much of your time with the same people
you'd really hope you'd make a friend or
two Scarlett Johansson said it's really
a result of 10 years of knowing somebody
and being being able to have a kind of
intimacy with them that I think you get
from just spending a lot of time with
somebody and knowing their soft
underbelly number nine both Cobra Kai
actors have very similar backgrounds
after starring in the hit series The
Karate Kid this has bonded them William
zabka said we are both from New York I
was actually born in the city and lived
in Long Island till I was a kid he's
from Long Island we'll drive home we'll
have the same complaints the same
thoughts you know so we drive you know
we get lost together crank the music
together number 10 Cobra Kai co-stars
Jacob Bertrand and cholo maraduña do
tons of fun stuff together off screen
like off-roading karate training and
getting dinner Bertrand calls maraduena
cholito and has at least once also
called him the sassiest goober alive
sholo just can't wait to be 70 years old
when they live together in Laguna with
their wives and their magic cards sholo
posted for Jacob's birthday I'm so proud
to call you my friend and so excited for
all the world we have yet to explore
together you're still asleep right now
in the other room but I promise to wake
you up with 21 sweet punches to the
giblets yikes if we were Jacob we would
officially dread our birthday every year
number 11. lifelong friends since
childhood being the same age Leonardo
Dicaprio and Toby Maguire ran into each
other at a lot of auditions Leo spotted
Toby on the street and jumped out of his
mom's car saying I was like Toby Toby
hey hey and he was like oh yeah I know
you you're that guy but I just made him
my pal when I want someone to be my
friend I just make them my friend they
were part of a thespian troop with a
notorious name they worked together on
several films including This Boy's Life
another film they'd only agreed was
supposed to be a short called Dawn's
Plum that they stopped from being
released in America for its treatment of
women and of course the Great Gatsby
despite their slightly different
Lifestyles the two have remained good
friends number 12. in our memories Sansa
and Arya had a bigger age Gap than they
actually did however not the case and
definitely not the case for Maisie
Williams and Sophie Turner who only one
year apart in age formed a great Bond
considering each other like family
thanks to their growing up together on
set they got matching tattoos and
everything of the day they got their
roles on Game of Thrones
0708.09 a pretty great date too that was
the best I don't know that I've ever had
a day as good as that no I agree that
was our best friend day ever yeah number
13. Dylan O'Brien and Tyler Posey first
met when they did a screen test for Teen
Wolf they're such good friends they even
agreed to be each other's best man at
their weddings sadly Dylan O'Brien won't
be returning for the Teen Wolf movie it
was kind of thrown at him last minute
and it just didn't work with his
schedule but he will be in the audience
on opening night number 14. Chris
Hemsworth and Tom Hiddleston met at
Kenneth brana's house after being cast
in the MCU obviously Tom didn't hold it
against Chris that he got the role of
Thor over him it just made more sense
that way Hiddleston said I made it very
fast and firm friendship with him
because we were playing Brothers in this
enormous thing and it felt like we were
brothers by the end in some way I love
you man
number 15 Demi Lovato and Selena Gomez
were friends ever since they were in
Barney together then they both became
Disney stars and did Princess Protection
Program together and even had a shared
YouTube channel but over the years
they've drifted apart life happens and
that's okay and this is my best friend
in the entire world um
friendships they come and they go some
are for life and some are just for a
short time we all love each other like
family but to be here with them is
incredible when you're an actor who
travels all over the country or all over
the world it must be hard to keep in
contact what would you do for your best
friend let us know in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things
foreign